evening all and with my good friend
Chris known as chess explained so we're
here to cover now game 9 isn't it Chris
yeah should be a game nine right yep so
we've got four games left in the match
and yeah things get really yeah tied now
only four games left means any mistake
might cost so much so hmm yeah let's see
what happens so playing white was
girlfriend and he kicked off with d fall
and we saw HD Knight f6 from an end so
that's good because it means that maybe
a sloth defense well occur and in fact I
have to say for yes we see e 6 and in
fact they've liven up things for the
spectators haven't they because usually
most GM's will play my f3 here one night
Queens Indian Territory yeah i'm not a 3
is some i'm not sure that it's really
more popular maybe it is um yeah let his
reason so i played so often allowing the
NIMS oh but well on Ida three alan day
usually what wouldn't play the Queen's
Indian but would go for a Queens gambit
declined here yeah and this is quite
quite funny because both players
actually play a play this is black also
and the same applies now for the groom
third which also would be an option for
Anand maybe not with four games to go
too risky maybe for this but the goon
father also was played by a girl fun now
in this match so there's a little bit of
a case to choose an opening that the
other players prepared as well so but
Jeff and went not see through which are
actually expected you to question me I'm
not quite sure why I spoke yesterday to
to to a friend of mine on CH s cube and
we discuss what kind of opening would
get and I guess then not quite sure why
I came up with this but
somewhere I was right okay my god fish
should be formed okay brainchild of our
limbs of each one of the most
influential writers I think well a lot
of GM swear bindings which about some
dones I thought yeah my sister was
really good of names which is my system
interesting anyway um yeah well let's
not get into this you might guess I me
to debate them yep okay Rubenstein's
movie free i remember a club plan
recommending to me this once every race
solid move Rubinstein ikea bed yeah i'm
not i'm not quite sure i didn't look
look up yet what girl font usually a
place here which line i think in general
he he plays 93 animal 30 mg 3 the
catalan so the names o is a bit of a
surprise but will he three is some yeah
maybe though the main line together with
quincy too and it's I think it's really
a good line for for those kind of games
here because white is solid but still
it's a strategically complex position
that usually arises it depends a bit on
the variation which is chosen but them
this is usually leading to an
interesting game and I think we got an
interesting game so let's see what
happens so I'm like castles here which
is maybe the most popular alternatives
of course nah Bishop d3 yeah okay and I
thought this was gonna head get them may
be there sorry I thought this might be
heading for an IQ p situation well it
becomes more evidence that the isolate
Queens pawn situation could arise very
shortly where we get this in the game so
d5 and after my f free we see c5 and
usually this central tension well it
gives white the isolate Queen's pawn
here because I think whites are not kind
usually on playing
c-type well we can but I suppose it's
interesting well what do you think about
this is is there isn't an option for
white to go for the ice at Queen's ball
or is it would it be that good white
cancelled here and let black saddle
white with the isolated Queens pawn the
odds he takes seed xt5 and you meant to
txt five as an alternative now yeah yeah
one one one point could be that black
also can take on g4 and then what would
get the IQ p anyway all right yeah just
just one thing because night XD for is
just a nothing moving here and you got
965 yeah putting more pressure on see
free quickly it could be possible but
black also after seat xt5 could just
play you takes d5 with non particular
problems many of course yes who sits the
isolated Queens pawn is not really an
issue here for black gum I think I'm was
not isolated I mean because that's
shooting that anyway now yeah I think
castles on move seven is virtually the
only move that is ever played yeah so on
but after this we've got a big big
parting of the ways yeah black can play
multitude of setups what the are not
actually played some yeah usually called
the cop offline cap off plate this I
don't know very often very nice results
also the absolute mainline still I think
might be yeah maybe the cob of line is
the mainland nowadays but 96 would be
the classical way to play this and then
after a three we got um got the absolute
Rubinstein mainline a three Bishop takes
c3 be takes you three GC for Bishop c4
and so on it goes on and on very
complicated also yeah so this is this is
a very good line on for both players
actually to play for win because you've
got those strategic imbalances here wide
squat position here but
the bishop 1 C 1 is not yet regrade so
he needs to work to make his bishops
count and black has a nice bone
structure you can play a five later
maybe like so it's a very complicated
kind of position which is more suitable
really if you yeah may want to play for
winners black so i think i'm just some
very very reasonable and it's arguably
the most solid line at all that all that
is possible so what do what he played is
clarifying the center here you're taking
on c4 and Dungey for ya so after eight
tags leave although there is potentially
this dangerous pain which makes maybe
the bishop look a bit silly having to
sometimes retreat it's on pin but flip
those other ideas just to protect the
night though is we're going about to see
but the ice that yeah very often I'm
sorry sorry yeah yeah very often blacker
never retreats but just captures aunty
three it's it's quite unusual to to
retreat em at some point you just
usually except here to to take on c3 the
kind of position that arises in the game
is actually very typical of the
variation so now black plays be six
right and this is this is the mentioned
cup of line mine and I think white is
got them lots of options really in in
this opening it's very difficult also i
had to study i tried myself for some
time in the past and had really huge
problems to figure out all the different
move order sent and so on but what Jeff
and plenty Bishop g5 it's a very logical
move against it to pin the night and put
some pressure here also on the d5 square
yeah i think you know black is going to
strengthen his grip on the light squares
and when he takes also see for as well
as d5 leave for i think a critical for
blacks put more pressure on so but
Bishop e7 lesion yeah these two key
squares putting more
so you write this this Bishop doesn't
have to retreat and that's not the
intention here the pin is not doing
anything particularly at the moment of
danger so Queen yeah too okay so black
can't do anything radical the moment he
will just be leaving his rookie both of
you choice there's nothing radical at
the moment for black to do apart from
try and set up a blockade maybe on d5
soon yeah black set up sets up his
pieces so ammonius Lee and get one idea
you will see later like I tries to do so
now BTW seven yeah of course 37 motto c6
or anything you need to keep f6d a
six-night protected let's have a look at
96 then they'll be simply something like
nights he for a bit more pressure on a
second sore ism something more crushing
hair yeah it's just in a way just a wall
square maybe just wrote 81 I'm not sure
out of 95 95 g5 maybe even d5 ah yes
because now there's no taking as it
takes an attacking that Bishop oh yeah
it takes like mitosis is lasting husband
he loves very uncomfortable okay yeah he
need city needs to go on that BTW 7
which is also really they're the kind of
setup blacker black wants to was to get
mmm okay so um now Brooke I see one was
right ya hear what I think has got maybe
has played off all needle moves if you'd
ride I guess so but ok the stroking
offer make some sense of course and I
think this is important is that because
a lot of openings can lead to this sort
of isolate Queens pawn position a lot of
variations with different openings
across a whole spectrum of enemies can
result in this short yeah yeah but
usually this the specific kind of setup
with the bishop on
form arises other from the limb so as we
got yours or from from the pan of
variation of the caro-kann this is also
a very common transposition right so
Karpov got this set up numerous times
and he both played both the names of and
the cons it's also reason why I got it
so often so he could could could put it
up against both these openings on and
now I'm we got something which is a
[ __ ] uncommon this early whoopsie ADA I
looked at through it up briefly on
before we started the video it's a bit
uncommon this move but the setup is the
setup which arises is very very normal
white not plays Bishop b3 actually
there's a major tactical frat is now
officially a free now because if it
takes you know the bishops hanging and
it is why G tanks so that get out of the
way of bishop maybe Bishop takes a free
was a right yeah what needs what needs
to do this and now Bishop takes III this
is so important black deliberately gives
up his Bishop and I'd explain why but
curiously enough an entreaty didn't
follow the usual plans there which is
surprising he pled Queen c7 now right
this is the shows my am like also in a
way to convey 31 sir a nice and secure
square for ice queen on c7 and this
sorry um oh yeah we got an equation here
altis books are you back so I didn't
hear you from aminah creases yeah so you
know it it tells me I've gotten a
connection phone you still there yes
okay I had had some connection problem
message here on skype some black has got
a nice ammonia set up to and can dump in
the night so we can actually move
through their 69 and now we transposed
here from typical isolated Queens
position to a hanging born position
because white go see for no actually is
there something else going on tactically
here because c4 does actually support
potential td5 but say white played you
know a casual move like rookie 1 i'm
just wondering about Knight g4 here
again it's like Bishop f free as
effective be crude Queen h2 but no
because there's no d5 interrupting the
bishop and is that possible for black
was that and rubbish move my g4 here
prob probably is rubbish I'm just just
checking that no no no no young you're
absolutely right the issue is if you set
up the game then I set up the game it is
just the same you get white wine CF
alright so now I'm so now now actually
the normal move would be Nyjah for the
normal movies 9g for here yeah but ok
but day five here might be an
interesting move oh not sure it's yeah
the curious thing is that Anna didn't
played usually this position Rises
without the rook moves rook c8 and Roxy
one I already said that rook c8 is a
little bit of a rare move and usually
maybe maybe you just spotted something
very important um because the rooks now
on the board mean that white could maybe
play d 5 in the position without the
rooks being on c 1 and c 85 verb is just
just upon that black and grab on d5 and
naji force the main main idea here two
or one really important idea to try to
release the pressure here so when I was
absolutely shocked that Anna took on f3
and not only me as we loaded the co
comentary on on the mosque our feet away
website and he was completely stunned
that took on f3 because this is so so
weird in this position um so maybe maybe
Nancy 45 is a point I'm not sure what
they discussed on the website because I
on the life comenten because I didn't
see the first 20 minutes I only yeah I
only swede i was going on and on when
did I hand take on f3 I don't understand
it and so on yeah then this weird energy
for would be a normal idea maybe d5 is
some it's a problem here it's a little
bit different because you've got the the
rooks on the embassy farm but still to
Bishop f3 there's even another
alternative which is which we could
briefly show actually what will be
frettin Queenie full now even crew
crudities returned for white frame 20
foot but my supposed Knight f6 I'm not
sure about that yeah yeah what what what
you could go to jail LOL ours is each XD
5c txt five and twenty six maybe Bishop
e7 right Bishop e7 oh yes Bishop e7
numbers also maybe 26 is a syllable
maybe you need to go to be eight or
something I'm actually isn't it isn't
cool yeah h7 remove hair for quick Air
Force h7 or Queenie for this kind of
stuff no f5 the Hollister's f5 yeah um
yeah yeah right maybe um I'm like weenie
for this Knight f6 I'm not really sure
okay it's very very possible that maybe
for some reason I'm out more or less
accidentally yeah inserted this rook c8
move and was now irritated about
defiance this is possible just
speculating I have no idea the thing is
that Bishop takes f3 is just horrible
I'd like it looks bad because blacks
weakened already is nine squares
misgivings really horrible is maybe too
hard work but black suffers yeah really
yeah so but justjust if you take it bit
vectors one and that's another
interesting idea just just just show
what kind of ideas this position has if
that could also play h6 here and then
let's save the ship to h4
make sense and then night age five this
is also the typical idea in those kind
of positions with the idea to play
Knight to f4 yes so so this is a little
bit of an unusual kind of hanging porn
position because black has got those
kind of counter play ideas and I was if
the other thing is not working i was at
least expecting this to kick this to be
played but maybe what about d5 now but
then i can plan data for you aah um
maybe the wrist Bishop is Evelyn Queene
you fool hand I'm Sam another's like g6
sorry there's no cheese sticks query for
my musics okay uh yeah between you for
now I can display at five mmm yeah I'm
ever so d5 is not an issue you be sure
this would have been this would have
been another interesting idea which
looks at least on the first side
somewhat more attractive than taking on
it on a three this was a bishop
generation mmm yeah you can just take it
or play Oh planada phones or neither for
looks like it's somewhat awkward thing
but just take it and i think that's it
in terms of problems for luck ah one one
thing is what blackened can maybe do
here it's just if you take on G 38 x h
take g3 hmm then if maybe it's possible
just to to to take the knight on f3 and
play you five alright yeah trying to
establish the night on C fine if they
fine that'll be nice yeah right this
this is the kind of idea that black
hairs and this was also I think roughly
and wishes idea and taking on a three to
play a five and sort of falsity power to
move to get squares on c5 and so on you
know maybe this is an instant equalizer
here unless white it's got something
directly here then this is should be
fine we need for g6 is nothing maybe no
I think this looks it looks fine so
these are kind of typical I
years to to generate play here for black
but for whatever reason you took on f3
maybe this was based on some
miscalculation or you remembered some
variation wrongly whatever how to tell
you so it's not like black is losing its
just a very uncomfortable position after
this yeah the two bishops versus the two
nines and hanging pawns are quite
dangerous as well yeah yeah and the the
problem is some what the move that black
would like to play is of course 'if I've
hmmm you would like to play you 5pm to
to sort of clarify the center and
something that t take c5 would be
immediately fine for black but yeah this
is mad with Bishop f5 the typical I
never sports and and yo your end and
some really nasty pins oh you're
frightening bishops likes have six now
yeah for that pin oh yeah this is at
least this is one issue maybe there's
something even worse but this looks am
but no of c2 eh is it so terrible this
was a queen age free might be handy
uh-hmm know that does look good um yeah
that looks bad for blank yeah maybe roki
eighth step possible is it so bad
disposition don't you just take me alex
the other one sorry on the other of
course yeah this is sir um and maybe
maybe c5c five really maybe c5 here yeah
this is dangerous possible now is now
yeah it looks dangerous you cannot
really take it twice because of your
various things like you should have six
and I much it didn't calculate here yeah
it's just instant idea Brad and it's
crushing yeah it looks it looks very
dangerous
king size is dropping off yes c5 so yeah
absolutely i see that might be an idea
than a bishop tative well maybe there
was some misconception there so he
couldn't take it you know need played
rook f28 sort of preparing this yes and
um what I'm just ruin our VR f.2d one
very logical and now yeah what-what can
like do is sitting there with two nights
against two bishops yeah and it's so
quite open position where white has
chances to open it up further with c5 at
some point or d 5 or whatever yeah and
you don't really know what to do yeah
it's an if um if you played 86 here now
what if so if he plays a farmer guests
will be punished yeah I think it's just
it's visual by five again and this is
even worse because you don't have to
Roxy to Yates at all yeah oh dear oh
dear and exerting pressure on d Seminole
Texas movie and if neck no moves the
rock then you can see five again like
Roxy to a 8 or ba de whatever then you
have seen so far down strums Morgan's
yeah this looks yeah so yeah so black
was in trouble a bit here so he plays
thank ya eggs um not bishop and sure
which looks quite a menace now on this
diagonal unchallenged yeah okay that's
not comfortable now Queen d6 you also
must take into account that at this
point um I think girl font had spent
like 25 or 30 minutes and are not more
than an hour so somehow it was
uncomfortable with this it's not quite
sure how eagerly it got into this I mean
the limbs Oh wasn't really a surprise I
mean Jeff I'm playing 93 it's white
playing at e3 basically means that it's
a limo because everything else is just
rubbish in the world championship match
so I'm
it's a bit strange that he somewhat got
wrong footage Ian in the opening and got
those this quite miserable position yeah
it's it's quite it's quite an awesome
plan may be a bit of a matter of chase
how how how bad US has this so the
defense of bishops like an ex Midler in
the in the broadcast he was basically
stating if I had this position as wide I
would want to win everything else is
unacceptable so yeah but it's this is
really this year it's exactly the key
point maybe of the game you know girl
phantom got into a long thing and played
c5 which basically wins the queen but
the question is if if white as white can
win or not after this yeah he just plays
this slowly say he played Bishop be one
just protect d4 and keep the hanging
porn hanging wedgie yeah we're almost
not key for was not really hanging yet
oh yeah sorry because I should I h7
check the suggestion in the broadcast
what I think you should too 2g3 to
attack the Queen and something along the
lines of Bishop going to be four then a
three oh yes again that little cheapo
with the choice yeah yeah Queen a 50 d
router and then we should be six was the
line that they had in the broadcast this
one sample idea what's this it's not
entirely clear on if this is so
brilliant for why do I just better in a
way but maybe it was also a
consideration on girl fans part here
with playing c5 what he did in the game
he basically won the Queen for this rook
and rook and might I think it was and
after after the game continuation you
make sure that you can torture your
opponent for a couple of moves and you
can absolutely never
and the alternatives I'm just not
complicated and maybe after he just won
but the last game in 17 moosie he was
maybe not not too keen on having a so
complicated position just one which she
cannot do said he can press on for ages
I think most people would have fought
our whites winning half the winning the
Queen line this D take c5 it's like this
cheapo has actually being played in the
game yes it's really a debatable in the
broadcast it was interesting they had
Michigan swidler and both stated that
the thought said c5 was maybe
objectively a mistake they wouldn't play
this and they both said really so they
wouldn't wouldn't win the Queen it's a
matter of keeping the tension at that
expression keeping the tension or not
you are the more complex to keep the
tension but they might be best yeah but
it's it's this kind of decisions are
super difficult super difficult and if
you if you if you look at the game
continuation maybe we should really put
it on the board to show that why white
is winning a queen and so on so it's
Bishop Bishop h7 trip here and the
question is after Luke take you six here
c1 checkbook t1 whoopsie eight yep yeah
and this kind of position this is what
what girl phone needed to to judge yeah
how are my winning chances in this kind
of position and yeah that's that's
really difficult to judge from the
conformity position I yet to hear to
assess this once the five five or six
moves ago and here it's basically a
matter or for what kind of set up like
an reaches got annoyed and um and i dint
look classy porn important for 96mm for
the Queen and the question is can you
build up a fortress or or Kenny can you
not do it and this is not easy to do to
judge and well-wishes summer hold this
but the it's not them
chem shouldn't make figure out the
results of like a black managed to draw
this position oh you spoiled it oh
there's something will go nuts but okay
they have hearing loss is pain just
kidding now with we don't know the
result we with you don't know right so
age free here so can this fortress
concept is very important you know
Michael Adams he was playing Hydra and
the only game he drew was when he set up
a fortress putting his king on d3 it's
amazing he drew with the supercomputer
Hydra so it was like five and a half
half the fortress concept is really
important sometimes to secure draws
isn't it it's yeah impenetrable fortress
so efficiently those kind of kind of
positions where you are sort of in
trouble and can maybe give up your queen
a bit like leg in this game you you're
feeling trouble and you give up your
queen for let's say look and Fisher
bookend now look n tonight fortresses
are somewhat rarer in comparison to Luke
and Bishop hmm so um this is some yeah
interesting to see so 95 and I g6 which
is important because it basically forces
forces why to take on f6 you cannot
really play Bishop g3 and just forgot
why I mining coins yes fool is I know
though it was yeah this is also an idea
really good its route to see two groups
oh yeah this is instantly drawing
because why turn needs to put the Queen
somewhere where it keeps the one
protected and then you can take or do
you want to take a two and then it's an
immediate rozeboom food yeah see if the
the icon is gone then it's you could
even argue that like you try to just to
do a little bit of probing yeah maybe
without any success all most likely
without any success
but white cannot win this is this is a
one hundred percent clear so what after
96 is forced to check in at six and this
is important of course because what
White's material just got reduced and
the looks I exchanged also so we would
and now really we got this kind of yeah
pure fortress position can like set up a
can of formation which sort of consists
of pieces which protect each other
perfectly and white cannot really
penetrate and yeah what what we should
mention here is what what would be the
ideal kind of fortress from black here
is some rock on d5 and upon an a5 this
would be quite simple to hold because
the rook controls the fifth-ranked which
also um kind of stops any ideas from
white to push his pawns like G for FY h
1 and so on so this kind of fortress
would immediately draw but black cannot
set it up you plays rook c7 which also
protects this point could be a dangerous
France this April game the only threat
yeah yeah like blacks problem sir could
be a combination of the a porn it's a
porn and their seven which is a weakness
and needs to be protected by the rook
and white some are pushing up the
kingside pawns yeah and sort of
disturbing lack some coordination and
yeah what what does now is trying to
improve his position a bit yeah pushing
the a porn is very very logical to to to
gain some ground there with the a porn
so in case of yeah you winning the ape
on your own upon is actually advanced
but this gives the night chance to
centralize quite seemingly powerfully so
do ya right i think and i couldn't he
couldn't couldn't prevent this okay
since in this 95 this yeah this is not
only five is the other kind of setup
which is actually the setup I am just
offer to hold this the knight on d5 are
now basically a rock just flipping on C
797 bit and you're just biding time but
yeah this is all so basically what
happened so it doesn't matter now about
queen bee sevens that's just ignored
queen bee sevens if you tell you then
your queening the porn but with the
nightmare you just you just leave it
there and just do something else you
just ignore it right so again 8-7 Queen
D for which looks like a powerfully
centralized queen but he needs to do
something else now if he's gonna this
and now this looks a bit risky this next
move from black LS here I have some
engine analysis here I thought this was
the critical moment where if what had
any winning chances personally I thought
this was the moment in the game
according to engine to the move g4 might
be good try because if you leave this
earth porn your kings of it's safer on
the same rank I thought gee for hair
should I just show this engine life and
analysis earlier so say it's very it's
very much possible that that white hair
sir some idea here which is maybe
winning or very testing the black on you
exist LOL post if you undermine the
night outpost that's the seller game is
now so say black ink i think in the in
the live broadcast this video was mostly
worried about f4 here from like not
taking air for all right not so you just
a fool as you said computers and
fortress positions are not to be trusted
but I I see a point I think maybe this
is an idea because right now can maybe
push h 45 you will combine this year
like Queen to e5 h4 h5 chief are you can
you can pro pro pro Brown there yeah
it's it's but i think that the
difference between playing fo and g4 and
immediately putting g4 is quite
difficult to to assess him in a game and
you also would need you to look to look
at this this deeper yeah the computer to
see if if there's something but here's a
line which might give one but it's a
tags which the ok might not be as good
as f4 because he white and then ran now
add one again going for f5 and it starts
to destabilize this is just an example
variation that e6 can be a weakness here
for example like this and Queen f6 and
it starts to look a bit rocky now blacks
position it's about a porn advantage
call into engines Houdini air it starts
look rocky here and as there's two
weaknesses that's dangerous so that that
way i can write unfortunately s got
still upon the jeep on hmm if you'll get
rid of this point it's immediately it
wrong really difficult yeah it's
difficult sorry this was this final
position if you've been a judge on the
sixth exchange is just the wrong so what
would black my hair and um yeah I don't
know this look so it doesn't look
comfortable that's for sure yeah okay
but as you say f4 yeah I'm not really
sure I didn't analyze that mean I should
have sorry driver is this was just what
what's when I mentioned in the broadcast
out I was just watching this son I
didn't analyze myself I was just
watching this game like yeah like
watching a game of football or something
it is maybe it might be a sort of King
March like this to h5 I know I don't
know no I'm not sure ok ok that's
complicated so f five ok is it asking
for g4 well he plays F for which I think
if he's going to play g4 it looks very
risky now with his King safety there's
not in the checks what everyone hey hey
what could you use his paws similar to
the variation users just show it but he
didn't allow this at formal and I sure
if it is good it was just what what what
was mentioned in the bra
caused by best fiddler so okay let's
let's go on route 27 lectures by it's
time to connect them white um intended
to bring asking to edge for this is an
invitation for a queen age height right
here that's quite dramatic but it's not
doing anything deadly on a chain just
here yeah I'm you're funny enough yeah
it's not doing much it looks scary right
hello so no eggs protecting GA from any
check so Queen goes around the boards
and now h5 the committal poor move maybe
butter and now an interesting King move
King h4 interesting position yeah why
does the stress trying something here
it's not like he doesn't have any ideas
one idea would be to to bring us sir
Queen nah 22 to g5 like I only be 3g 3g
five yes and to sort of destabilizing
the position but we would see like an
amazing resource here um to the scene no
oh yes he's trying to get round to g3 to
g5 yeah so nighty full stops queen G
free so Queen CA looks dangerous Knight
f6 now queen bee ain't um so did I miss
the amazing resource so it should I've
rewind yeah just to adjust to two moves
here let's say Quincy three year we put
on the board jana hai 24 and let's let's
look at Queen h8 just for just for a
moment Queen I joins yeah now just just
just to show just to show the idea and
Blackwood let's say black place look d6
here which looks completely insane but
it's giving up h5 is over this is yea
high five yeah right let's put it on the
boardwalk g6 just just some move to have
to say on the reform now take a green TX
h 5 King g7
at black is winning Blass winning rook
da 2 h8 is not not avoidable here Oh
blimey awful you can do anything this
looks bad for the king the King looks
with silly hair it's not able to get
back the night and the porner
embarrassing scene 2 moves and white
cannot do anything it's amazing it's
really amazing maybe resource here
absolutely I blimey so this h5 porn
isn't so it's more of a Bates than a
weakness it's a beta 1 a very silly
position if you want to yeah and it was
quite funny in this podcast because
swindle was our always a little bit of
doubting if this would all this general
position would hold for black and maybe
he's got some problems that's on and
when he spotted this trick which she did
pretty quickly it was really impressed
and he said ok if you can even give up
the H porn with shake then this is it
wrong yes absolutely blimey that's quite
convincing evidence really a cool quick
but ok and queen edge Edric g6 a bit of
a silly move maybe but just to show the
idea it was coming up in different other
lines in some other lines I'm so black
really doesn't even need to a different
eh porn funny enough all right so um
Queen see a tree guts yeah so 960 some
bait maybe girlfriends gutter these
realized that I actually our fortress
time is it he's probably realized by now
okay there's nothing I can do perhaps
but he's still gonna do a few questions
so Queen yay it's his trying its utmost
here yeah ok so now rookie a subset and
now another committal pull move then g4
whoa he is trying something can hear the
last last try okay so g4 if he gets in
g5 that will be very horrible for the
black king safety with Quinjet like
mating alley so it has to be taken and
and it's two choices to take by Knight
g4 I suppose there's Queen g8 winning
isn't it on the spot
nghe 54 in syrup ah yes wins the brook
yep so he has to take with the porn okay
so porn sack for queen e 5 which looks
dangerous for Queen g5 to win the night
for a moment but the night simply
retreats here offering back the G porn
and jig is it ah it's just he it's are
hanging by a thread here oh yeah this is
other guys are your Knights protecting
you seven so the check and the check
here it doesn't matter mine's protecting
ye seven yeah it looks all very closely
I like maybe some refinement at some
point so mature maybe they if they find
something later the deeper analysis how
white could could do something before
now I said no no it's it's really it's
gone it's over the tensions go there
this is why the expression maintaining
the tension is profoundly powerful
because I think a lot of club flyers
often simplifying they had this position
when I could have just increased and
tortured the upon a lot more but once
you reach a clarified position then
there's nothing you can do sometimes
well especially like fortress um so you
know f6 end you've got this everything
protect each other kind of situation mmm
so Queen g2 King can even go back now 2
h8 to support maybe checks if needed but
yeah tried to try to win so Quinn wants
a threat or something himself yeah but
once yeah and the King just goes back
now and here well everything's
protecting yeah the 96 to the rook the
roots protecting the pawn king of
lectures deck just make turkey came
all-star my clasp or move tries a bit
pointless I think isn't it f5 do you
don't do take that Paul oh gee you don't
want to leave that pawn do if you play
be five that's probably very dangerous
isn't it can play you five to try to win
the flag but maybe it's not justified
you take their five it's just the draw
yeah but okay see if this is not
dangerous check here I suppose again you
got a fortress here and you've just got
this dangerous pass porn now yeah you
can you can you can easily easily maybe
but you can try to reduce with white
yeah in fact check and rook g7 win the
Queen hair heads the king and queen is
stupid in this position but not not the
greatest yeah yeah a bit I think it's
it's really all when terms of rain
chances maybe this this is this could
could have been and if we look at this
match later when it will be finished
with whatever result if Kevin doesn't
win the match this may be what's the
game way spoil it maybe do so for me
it's just just like he got this really
great position out of the opening two
years already and we kept more yeah yeah
yeah i mean that's unfortunate he had
the two bishops dangerous hanging pawns
oh it's this doing overview in summary
then so an enzo engine kind of little
disaster but um and then seemed to come
out of that disaster with with the idea
of a queen sack for a fortress which was
plunged into maybe white should have
exercise some caution and maintains the
tension more because he did in theory
hey bishop pair this hanging pawns
constant threats of c5 and d5 so a quiet
way of playing the position is rooks
very harmonious so the quite way of
playing position would have been just to
kick that queen with Bishop g4 is you
say that did look impressive to
celebrate the dark squares very simply
you know sometimes yeah so c5 looks very
very tempting though I think a lot of
most pliers in cobb chatswood place see
five here wouldn't night to try and
exploit that Queen it's hard to it's
really hard to tell I ask myself what up
but would I have done I'm not sure
really can tell I think it's pretty
clear if you if you see the line with
the
the one of the Queen which happened in
the game you see that ok you can never
lose with why'd you have some chances to
win but if you do you really do you
really have some things I'm concrete
winning chances how to tell I think I
wouldn't have played and I also think
girlfriend wouldn't have played c5 if
this would have been let's say the last
game and he needs to win it everything
else is unacceptable like and a must-win
situation then he certainly wouldn't
have plates you fight i'm pretty sure
because it's very obvious of course also
to him that white is better in the in
the middle game with Bishop e3 are or
even some other but c5 is the kind of
move you can you can play in this match
situation where draw is not not bad and
you certainly won't lose which is also
pretty nice future the chess game if you
know that you don't lose so you know
this position does look ridiculous if
Queen before and I free you can't say
that and you have to play it's like your
Queens like a computer Queen what is it
doing on on 85 it just looks like an
ideal position it's interesting yeah
we're Queen a 5-4 support on e5 of
course this is the fin to nullify the
bishops isn't it once you get d 5 in
that night c5 some point yeah so let's
say Bishop d6 quite reliable what the
line that they had in though in the
broadcast and then then the e5 idea
again and this is a bit different if you
like now e5 mm-hmm if I that's what I'm
sir I've played you see ya I'm sorry day
for EIC five yeah no no it's a this is
different from the positions before
where white could have gone the Bishop
f5 so it was about five is pointless yet
right because though we've got this
somewhat different Bishop 26 and this
isn't entirely clear right really in
fact I isn't sheep oh here isn't that
with rook takes see folks if those
around thing is better oh no excuse that
so I had an illusion there no there
isn't the cheapo I'm know potentially on
e 1 if the rook was
he won then there's a cheap hold because
the Queen's oh yeah if you play you
takes d4 here and there should be five
and this is maybe yeah maybe a thing
yeah it's it's it's difficult you know
difficult same okay interesting okay
interesting so this this looks great as
well to win the queen but some amazing
an exciting draw though a very exciting
draw because most beautiful would have
perhaps for why an interesting game
after those are kind of I'm not sure
narcotic first six games we've got some
pretty interesting chest the last three
games yeah yeah so okay white black was
setting up an amazing fortress and even
the h5 wasn't such a liability as we saw
in that amazing variation be a bait so
white tried something at the ends he did
try and here it starts the good look a
bit dangerous even if he blonde so yep
draw okay exciting hope everyone on
YouTube got something out of that thanks
Chris and I don't know if there's
anything else you want to say Eliza yeah
maybe we can we can do a quick quick
discussion what will happen tomorrow oh
yeah God again we've got game one is it
10 10 tomorrow on and white yeah so what
kind of opening will we get I did edit
guess the names of correctly yesterday
so I'd like to guess again I'm not
everything that people tell me that I
was just making this up that I guess
correctly so I guess again so I predict
the Queens gambit declined tomorrow do
you I hope it takes a fool then and then
could play efore he's white why doesn't
he try a fall to liven things up no no I
can't make a draw you mean voice far
more awesome yeah this is really a
common misconception that a formal would
be sharper than T for any crap like this
this is much more draw x-ray okay let's
not get into this okay I just say that
girl Fanta does
go for any g6 setups again and we'll
play Queens gambit to climb tomorrow or
maybe him maybe we got an imbecile again
with reverse cutters as possible well I
segments gambit declined okay all right
yeah thanks for watching I hope the
audio has been fine yes that's right try
to improve what we what we could do all
right okay okay everyone will carry on
next next game and I hope to see that um
all right thanks very much comments or
questions on youtube on both hawk both
all channels chess explaining
kingscrusher channels thanks very much